in a small silicon valley office salman
khan is using simple illustrations and
lingo to explain math science history
and even business concepts if this does
not blow your mind
then you have no emotion the 10 to 20
minute tutorials on khan academy.org are
free to anyone anywhere
sal you have found the answer man
hopefully we have a lot of work to do no
i'm serious because you've opened up the
world of learning to the world the best
way to get the the core of most issues
whether it's you know poverty health
care whatever is just happening even
democracy is making sure you have an
educated population and and so the
technology is now making it so that
the delivery cost of that education is
going pretty close to zero
instead he got 31 i said negative 31.
dean brettel uses khan academy as a tool
for homeschooling his two children what
i like about it and what i think the
kids like about it is that you can work
at your own pace they don't understand
the video they can pause it they can
rewind it they can watch it multiple
times second
and you already got the twos and with
khan you have to master all the material
before moving on with only hints to help
you if you're struggling with something
in a regular school
and uh
you don't get it but you take the test
and you get a c a c on the test can't
move on with a c here that's right
you're trying to kick teachers out
because that's what a lot of teachers
then start to think no it's it's the
complete opposite what it does at least
in my mind it would make the job of
teaching a lot more fun because they
come in every day and they get to
actually be
guides and mentors for these students
like fifth grade teacher richard julian
his los altos california school uses con
lessons in math class the software
tracks each student's progress by doing
that it allows the teacher
to know their students very well it
allows them to know their strengths it
allows them to know their weaknesses
khan academy is a non-profit but it's
backed by bill gates and google you
could make money from this you know
you can make a lot of money from how
many how many distinct users do you have
per month it's it's pushing two million
now you're the math guy
but a dollar a piece
isn't that much to charge
you're doing this for free partner
what gives
well you know uh if khan academy was for
profit it would limit the number of kids
who would use it
when i'm 80 i can say wow there's a
billion kids that use it and maybe we'll
continue to use it and maybe even after
i'm gone this can be an institution that
can last for 100 years or 200 years